how's it goin everybody it's Warren and
today is a big day because this morning
the Avengers in game Empire magazine
exclusive came out there's lots of
really good information in this issue as
well as interviews with the directors of
the movie the Russo brothers and Marvel
Studios President Kevin Feige but by far
the most interesting thing about this
article was referenced to the soulstone
the quantum realm and the dead Avengers
and I'll read and breakdown everything
they said in the article in this video
but a quick reminder about my giveaway
I'm giving away five imax tickets if
you'd like to enter for your chance to
win all I have to do is be subscribed to
my channel like this video and comment
down below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain so like I
said there's a lot of great information
in this article but what I want to focus
on right now is specifically where they
talk about the quantum realm the article
talks about how we know ant-man gets out
of the quantum realm due to the trailers
presumably due to one of those handily
placed time vortexes that he was
conspicuously warned to watch out for
and this is where the article gets very
very interesting it says these time
vortexes and the quantum realm could end
up being major players in the fight to
stick Thanos's Infinity Gauntlet where
the Sun don't shine in game could
involve a fair amount of time travel
with the original Avengers and Paul
Rudd's ant-man embarking on a desperate
quest to key moments from the Avengers
as history possibly to alter events that
lead to Thanos getting the stones think
back to the future part two but with
superheroes this is something that we've
all guessed for the most part the
Avenger is going back in time via the
quantum realm to stop Thanos from
getting the Infinity stones but listen
to this next paragraph in the article as
for the quantum realm well what if those
who were dusted didn't die what if they
were instead stored in the soul stone
the most important of all of tanis's
designer jewelry and what if there was a
way to get them back by infiltrating the
stone via the quantum realm that is huge
and it's directly from this Empire
magazine Avengers and Game article now
they're not coming out insane
this is going to happen this is the plot
of avengers endgame they're teasing us
with it by using what-ifs but let me
explain how this works every single
paragraph every single sentence every
single word has to be approved by
marvel I've worked with Marvel in the
past doing a promotion and I know this
to be true you can't just write whatever
you want in an article and post it it
does not work that way everything has to
be approved by Marvel's in gain
publicity team and marketing team and
most likely the Russo brothers and Kevin
Feige have the final say on what goes in
it like I said I've worked with the
Marvel promotional team in the past and
this is painstakingly true so this is in
this article for one of two reasons one
is that this is actually going to take
place in the film which is I think what
we all expect or two it is complete
intentional misdirection from Marvel the
Russo brothers for Avengers infinity war
and especially for Avengers and game are
being extra sneaky to make sure we don't
know anything about the movie really so
this could be to throw us off however I
don't think that's the case millions of
people are going to read this article
all around the world and Marvel will
want to give them some insight of the
movie not too much but some and the dead
Avengers being inside of the soulstone
is directly from the comics and the
Russo brothers say in this article that
jim Starlin who is the writer of the
Infinity Gauntlet saga for the comics
the Russo brothers said that he was a
big inspiration to them and the dead
Avengers being inside of the soulstone
in the comics was a really big part we
know the Avengers are going to go inside
of the quantum realm that's a given and
we know through various interviews that
the dead Avengers are going to come back
some way or another so maybe they don't
come back by undoing the snap like we
thought maybe they're inside of the
soulstone and they use the quantum realm
to access soul world somehow this would
certainly make a lot of sense and we
learned in Avengers infinity war that
the soul stone holds a special place
with all of the other Infinity stones so
it seems like there is a really good
chance that the Avengers will go inside
of the quantum realm and access the soul
world to bring back the Fallen Heroes
but let me know what you think about
this in the comments down below do you
think we'll see The Avengers travel
inside of the quantum realm to get to
the soul world or do you think this is
misdirection let me know your thoughts
and again don't forget to subscribe
comment and like the video so you can
enter the giveaway and stay up to date
with everything relating to Avengers
endgame and Marvel as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]